I think it's such an interesting story
because Star Trek's all about building
bridges and unity and peace and in that
spirit a couple of years ago I was
invited to come down to a little town in
South Georgia and direct an episode of a
web series called starship Farragut
hello Jean Michels oh good to see I've
got to get back to the enterprise I did
so made great friends and we decided
that it would be fun to join forces
we're coming together out of the pure
love of making something that we can be
proud of and not only do we have that
that one part love but we've got the
other part of people that know what
they're doing with the camera but the
sound with the makeup it's funny to
think about how the people who
participate in the project lend to the
reputation of the production it's not
just me as a host on Mythbusters it's
also Vic and Todd who are accomplished
voice actors Matt Busey accomplished DP
we looked at the original Star Trek
series they shot very quickly they had a
studio set up the lights were all up
high all hard light it doesn't look at
all like good lighting you know it's
supposed to look but I'm loving it
actually the great thing about Star Trek
continues is that it brings in
professional actors to to play these
iconic roles in their own way in their
own interpretation of who they are and
working with professional actors and
really dedicated talent and crew members
makes all the difference some of you may
know this some of you may not my father
was James Doohan the original Scotty in
the original series vic Mignogna got a
hold of me through facebook first I told
him no I said Vic I'm not an actor and
because there was some pretty big shoes
to fill with my father and either the
fans were gonna love me or they're gonna
hate I think he's got some actual Scotty
blood and I'm you know I mean I think
whatever magic his dad has Chris has if
you're gonna have somebody play Scotty
it might as well be his son the thing I
liked about Star Trek was not that there
were crazy aliens or that there were
monsters what I
loved about it what resonated about it
what I think still resonates about Star
Trek are the relationships that's maybe
what attracts people to it it's the
friendships as well as the amazing
stories and that's what I'm has a
wonderful miracle worker for our series
the crews from all over the country and
even from some other countries I mean it
all starts with all the local people
working here in Kingsland Georgia people
have dedicated whole months of weekend's
of their lives we have quite the group
because out of our group none of us are
really professional builders we've got a
lawyer we've got a reporter I happen to
be a retired military this is a labor of
love we come down here so pay for our
own food we pay for our own travel
expenses and I think that's one reason
why the team here works so hard and work
so well together when you're shooting on
on episodes everyone's there right there
giving up their own time to be there
time is precious so you get in in the
morning and you shoot the people here
are very proud of what we do going
around the sets if you look on the back
you're gonna see where they sign their
name we want people to leave their mark
here this is kind of part of history one
of the amazing things that we have here
at Star Trek continues is the accuracy
and the attention to detail dude that's
the rib name not the diamond and look at
that Queen oh my gosh
no idea how hard this is to get that
slate just perfectly that's one of the
fun things about being on set is like
everybody's an expert on Star Trek the
most valuable contribution I have to
start there continues is helping make it
accurate as we can make it to the
original series months of work go into
into finding the right fabrics finding
the right details look at these pieces I
mean what the hell is that I don't know
but it's amazing and and there are guys
who have studied these pieces and we and
reproduce them with amazing accuracy
I've spent too many years watching every
frame of every show and so Vic uses meet
somewhat as a Star Trek encyclopedia
I've been watching Star Trek since I was
eight years old there was something
about this show that just grabbed me you
know it was beyond anything I'd seen
before
it was beyond entertainment people loved
it so much and are so desperate to find
a family in it that when they do that
community feeds them in a way that I
don't think we get anywhere else very
visceral experience because we're all in
the trenches together this is truly a
special group of people these guys are
so dedicated and they work so hard and
they believe in what they're doing I
think we have such an a heartfelt tie to
these ideas these characters these
universes you want to finish that life
you want to imagine those stories and
those ideas and those adventures
continuing we're like this loot show
that could we put together an episode
and thought yeah maybe people might like
it I only see it getting bigger and
better if you look at this facility you
realize that no one person could ever do
this this took an amazing amount of
and collaboration we've kind of pooled
all of our talents our resources time
money skilled labor and created this
together and ironically be doing it with
Star Trek which celebrated unity and
coming together have any questions about
anything you've seen in Star Trek
continues leave them in the comments
below and subscribe to the wired Channel